want to get balanced now. Balance.
Balance.
I only mention these things to balance
out the sick idolatrous fascination with
Israel, but then we need to not be sick.
We need not We need to protect ourselves
from being sick fanatical on the extreme
opposite end.
Right?
Extreme opposite end.
We need to be biblically balanced,
biblically centered, Christ-centered.
We need to be Christ-centered,
Christocentric,
biblically balanced, not extreme on
either end.
Your allegiance isn't to a political
party. Let me remind you.
Your allegiance isn't to Israel or
Palestine. It's not.
Your allegiance is to Jesus Christ, and
I'm not trying to preach and only have
you be biased. I'm a dog. I deserve
hell. May God save me.
I want the Lord to save me and not give
me what I deserve.
But the fact is
you
are
Christocentric.
Christ-centered.
Christ is king and Lord of every sphere
of existence.
Every sphere of your existence, every
sphere of your life, he governs and owns
your politics,
economics, right? Every sphere,
sociopolitical, economic, marital,
martial, religious, he owns all of it.
I don't need to tell you that.
You should know this.
He's the Lord of your politics. Jesus
doesn't take a backseat to your
political decision. He doesn't. He's the
king and Lord of every cell of our
being,
the Lord of all of existence. He owns
everything, and everything must submit
to his Lordship, his rule.
But if you believe this, then you're not
going to be pro-Israel or anti-Israel.
You can't be anti-Israel,
but you can't be pro-Israel.
If Israel is right, you stand for that
which is right.
If Palestinians are being
indiscriminately massacred
because of these filthy dogs, Hamas, you
don't say, "Well, there are no civilians
in Gaza as long as Hamas exists."
That
No, that's not how Jesus operated.
Now, to show you that I am a Jew,
you may not like it.
Hey, the Bible says, "If you are born of
the spirit,
you are united to Christ, you are now
the Israel of God. You are Israel of
God." And I'll tell you what the name
Israel means.
What does the word Israel means? Genesis
32:27-28. We're going to see.
Why was Jacob's name changed Israel?
Well, we're going to see.
But first, where am I getting this from?
I'm getting it from Paul. Who's Paul?
Let me show you who Paul is.
Let me show you who Paul is. You ready?
And this Jew says to anyone, Gentile or
Jew, "You're baptized in Christ, you are
now Israel. You are a real Jew."
Because God
only credits
spiritual
lineage.
Physically, that has a role to play, but
the spiritual takes over the physical.
Let me remind you guys, balance. Can I
give you chapter and verse so we can put
things in balance, and hold me
accountable. I'm scared for myself.
Brethren, I do not trust myself. I cry
out to Jesus, "Save me from myself, my
flesh." Cuz I can be an extremist,
right?
Seriously.
That's why I say, "God destroy the cult
of personality. Do not idolize us, man.
We are not perfectly normal or healthy.
We're being perfected. We are capable of
sin and lapsing into shame, disgrace our
Lord. God forbid.
Look to those who finished race. Paul
finished race, he can't fall anymore.
Peter finished the race. Paul did it
They all finished the race.
Saint Moses the Black finished the race.
They can't sin anymore. They can't
disappoint you or the Lord. Look to them
as heroes to emulate. Don't look to me
or David Wood.
Especially some of us were sad excuses
for role models. Now,
what does Paul say? What is a true Jew?
Remind you all. What is a true Jew?
So yes, I'm a Jew
spiritually. I'm an Israelite
spiritually.
There you go.
You ready?
Do I need to remind you of these things
again?
Hey, right here.
Paul, the Jew of Jews. Let me see if
it's large enough that you can see it.
You can see it, right? It's large
enough.
We need to be balanced, man. Yeah, it's
large enough, right? The screen?
I don't need to make any larger, do I?
Let me know.
"For he is not a Jew who is one
outwardly,
All right there, man. I mean, that's New
Testament. For he is not a Jew
who is one outwardly,
nor is circumcision that which is
outward in the flesh.
But he is a Jew who is one inwardly,
and circumcision is that which is of the
heart by the spirit, not by the letter,
and his praise is not from men, but from
God." So are you circumcised spiritually
by your baptism, where the spirit unites
you to Christ, makes you a new creation?
Well, you're a Jew.
Hear that, Assyrian Chaldeans? You're
spiritually Jewish.
And who told us that?
Who? Look, Paul. Romans 11:1.
"I say then, has God rejected his
people? May it never be. For I too am an
Israelite, a seed of Abraham, of the
tribe of Benjamin." This Jew is telling
you, "You are baptized, you are the real
Jews."
See?
Who is he? Philippians 3:5. "Circumcised
the eighth day,
of the nation of Israel, of the tribe of
Benjamin, a Hebrew of Hebrews, as to the
law, a Pharisee."
This Hebrew of Hebrews, Jew of Jews,
from the tribe of Benjamin, says, "Hey,
you are baptized in Christ, you are the
real Jews. Any Jew who rejects Christ is
not a real Jew. He's only one
physically, which means nothing."
Galatians 3:26-29.
"For you are all sons of God, Galatians
3:26-29, through faith in Christ Jesus.
For all of you who are baptized into
Christ have clothed yourselves with
Christ. There's neither Jew nor Greek,
see? God doesn't look at ethnicity.
And he doesn't favor one race over
another. That's not God.
And God has never been like that, not
even the Old Testament. I've given you
receipts. Go watch my series. There's
neither slave nor free man. There's no
male and female. Men are not better than
women.
Men are not more loved than women. Men
are not
greater than women in the eyes of God.
What makes you greater is your
obedience, your faithfulness, your
holiness.
There'll be women of higher rank,
greater rank than men in the kingdom
because of their obedience, holiness,
faithfulness. In fact,
if you are Orthodox and Catholic,
you already believe the greatest
creature is not a man, it's a woman.
Right?
If you want to see how God dignifies
women, shows that he loves his daughters
as much as his sons,
you believe
the greatest creature
that God made is a woman,
not a man, and a Jewish woman.
And her name is Mary, our blessed queen
and mother.
Right?
You see how fair,
unbiased, impartial God is?
Okay?
That's what we believe.
So,
God does not love his sons more than his
daughters. That's a lie from hell. "For
you are all one in Christ Jesus. And if
you belong to Christ, then you are
Abraham's seed, heirs according to the
promise." You can't get more pro-Jew
than this.
That you say
the God of all creation, whom you
worship, became a Jewish man.
My God became a Jewish man.
He was an Israelite physically, and his
human nature, he's a Jew from the tribe
of Judah, cuz his holy Jewish blessed
mother gave to him his physical body,
human nature.
So, I love
a Jew
whom I worship as my God. How are you
going to say we're anti-Semitic?
How are you going to say I'm
anti-Semitic, man? I don't get it.
Romans 9:3-5.
I just want to remind you of this. We
need to be balanced. You guys can't go
extreme. There are Jews who love Jesus
that are your brothers and sisters.
There are Jews who love Jesus that are
being persecuted in Israel by the Jews
who think they're traitors. You know
that, right?
There are Jews who love Jesus that are
being beaten in the zone.
Those are your brothers.
Right?
You got to be careful of being fanatical
and extreme. A reminder to all of us.
"For I could wish" Look what Paul says
about Israel.
Let me start from one.
Does Paul hate Israel?
Does Paul
despise Israel and wants Israel to be
destroyed because they rejected the
Jesus. Look.
Look at his heart.
Romans 9:1-5, "I'm telling the truth in
Christ. I'm not lying.
God will hold me accountable if I'm
lying.
I'm telling you the truth.
My conscience is flying with me in the
Holy Spirit. The Holy Spirit
is convicting me to feel this way,
moving me to feel this way,
and God will hold me accountable if I'm
lying to you
in what I say.
That I have great sorrow, unceasing
grief in my heart. I don't rejoice over
the rejection of Jesus by my people.
It breaks my heart.
For I could wish that I myself were
accursed, separated for from Christ for
the sake of my brothers, my kinsmen
according to the flesh. See, he's
saying, "Those who are Jews according to
the flesh,
my brothers according to the flesh, not
my true brothers according to the
spirit."
He's saying, "I love them so much that I
would go to hell for them if that would
mean they would be saved."
Right?
You understand?
Paul never stopped loving his people.
As harsh
as he could be in rebuking them, he
loves them and says, "If I could go to
hell
in their behalf to save them, I would
choose that so they would be saved."
So, we need balance, right?
You see I'm trying to balance things
out, you fanatics out there going to the
extreme opposite end.
Right, Rumble?
God blessed Israel to be the first
nation to be given these privileges.
They're the first nation that God chose
to be his son on Earth.
They are the nation that saw the glory
of God appear.
They were given the covenants. They
received the law. They're given
temple service and the promises. What
promises? The redeemer would come from
them. Now, notice the greatest blessing.
Whose are the fathers? Abraham, Isaac,
and Jacob are their ancestors.
And the greatest blessing that God could
give any people,
God himself became
flesh from them, became a physical
Israelite.
And from whom is the Christ according to
the flesh,
who is God over all, blessed forever.
Amen. Now, notice what he's saying. Look
at the blessings he gave to these
people.
He gave them the adoption. That's one.
They saw the glory of God in the cloud.
That's two.
The covenants were theirs. Three. They
were given the law Moses. Four. They're
given the temple service. Five. They're
given the promises. Six. That Messiah,
redeemer, God would come.
And to them are the fathers, Abraham,
Isaac, and Jacob. That's seven, right?
One,
two, three, four, five, six, seven. And
the greatest blessing.
The greatest blessing.
God
became flesh,
a physical being, a human being
from them. He became a physical
Israelite,
an Israelite according to his humanity,
his flesh.
Who? The God who reigns supreme over
all. Who? The God who's praised forever.
Do you get?
Can you get any more pro-Jew than this?
We got it now?
To remind you guys, don't go into your
extreme fanatical hatred of Israel.
You don't become the extreme opposite.
You can't do that.
You cannot do that because then what
you're going to do is you're going to be
no better than the
other side that demonizes all
Palestinians saying there are no
civilians in Gaza.